long-range thermal cameras radar and
potentially even swarms of drones
they're part of a high-tech border
security system
that greece is testing to stop migrants
arriving
from turkey illegally some critics say
it's excessive and could
stop desperate people from seeking
shelter max sander now reports
from the town of porosh where he met
greek border police patrolling
the european union's frontier with
turkey
5 meters high and 27 kilometers long
this massive steel wall is almost
finished its main job
keeping refugees and migrants from
crossing into the eu
border guards patrolling the turkish
greek land border will soon be handed
additional high-tech tools
to carry out their mission long-range
cameras with thermal optics
radar and sensors will be part of the
so-called integrated border security
system
that will be introduced next month
from the greek border police tells us
the system will be able to automatically
detect groups of refugees and migrants
deep into turkish territory
[Music]
the new border surveillance system and
technical equipment will provide us with
new capabilities for
fast and accurate localization that will
help us to deploy our forces more
effectively
and safe personnel and maintain an upper
hand in the prevention of border
crossings
the border security system was approved
by the greek government following last
year's border crisis
back then turkey sent thousands of
migrants and refugees to the greek
border to build political pressure on
the eu
since 2015 the eu has invested three
billion euros into border security
research
the thessaloniki based road border
program is one such
project researchers have developed a
system for drones to operate
autonomously in swarms
here they patrol a designated area when
the swarm picks up suspicious activity
it passes on the information to an
operator
but according to the project coordinator
the system is not designed to let
machines take over
the hardware and the system is there
only to suggest
so the human is setting the mission
saying okay i want the drones to go
there
and patrol so the drones go there and
patrol when something is found
they create an alert they don't take a
decision but they issue an alert
they send it to the operator and the
operator decides
and he can say okay now you need to
patrol it
in this specific area because i found
something that is illegal
row border is in its final months of
testing the system could be issued to
border authorities across the eu
in the near future in brussels
not everyone welcomes these developments
some fear the emerging technology could
make it harder for refugees to reach a
safe haven
greece wants to give the impression that
the borders are now being more closely
monitored to reach their goal that
nobody will be able to come and request
asylum in greece
the goal of border controls must be to
guarantee access to asylum procedures
according to the rule of law
and greece is moving away from these
principles
insists human rights will be guaranteed
asked if individuals will still be able
to cross the border in future
he tells us police are always ready to
face
any threats here at the greek turkish
border
well i'm not joined by brussels
correspondent max sander who filed
that report from greece there max tell
us why is greece acting like this is
there lots of internal pressure
right so um police told us that they
need this technology
the greek turkish land border is roughly
200 kilometers long there's thick
vegetation on both sides
so what they told us is that there's
multiple opportunities a lot of
opportunity for migrants to slip into
greece undetected and they need this
technology to police the border
appropriately but let me put to you
into context or visit there at the
border usually journalists like us would
have no business in being there you need
you need an authorization by the greek
army by the greek
police to go there but they gave us a
rare opportunity to go there and see
what they were doing there what's what's
being put in place there see this
this this fence uh they wanted to tell
us about the
the integrated border security system
that is being put in place in order to
um have these pictures uh in the media
around the world not just for uh greek
um
rick voters uh to to show them that
greece is doing everything they can to
keep people out but also to
to signal to other european member
states that greece is
uh resolute efficient and strong in um
uh defending the border uh as they would
put it
and terence also plays a big role here
well what's the actual situation like in
the european union uh
now concerning the situation with
refugees
right so the situation is relatively
calm now if you compare it to 2015 2016
the the height of the so-called migrant
crisis or
to 2020 when we had that recent flare up
at the uh the situation with turkey
which we just saw on the report and due
to the coronavirus pandemic travel came
to almost to unhaul last year
especially for people coming from from
outside the
the the european union um but now these
numbers are going up again and we have
reason to believe that there will be
going up further also as
consequences from the coronavirus
pandemic uh this has led to
more political instability to more
economical uh
instability in countries where people
were leaving from already
so uh it's unlikely that the situation
at the border is going to stay um
as quiet as it is for long okay so
the uh greece basically doing the dirty
work there for for the eu what do
critics say
well the issue here that the fear is
that the
that this technology could be used um uh
could could be abused
and policing the borders um there have
been allegations against
greek border police greek the greek
kosovo but also to
border security forces from other eu
member states such as croatia
and italy that they were not granting
asylum seekers their rights to claim
asylum
there have been many many allegations of
so-called illegal pushbacks
meaning border security forces would
receive
people at the border and send them back
usually in a violent manner to the
country they were coming from
without granting them the right to claim
asylum and
the fear now is that if you have
technology like this uh
which you can utilize to surveil people
far
into say in this case greek territory
eight kilometers into greek territory
this gives you
a lot of time to prepare for people
coming and
if border police are not willing to give
grant these people their asylum requests
this technology could be could be used
to further discriminate against asylum
seekers
max sander there reporting thank you
you